a river of ice the size of great britain
this is thwaite gasia one of the biggest
in antarctica
currently any flow of water is held back
from entering the ocean by an ice shelf
a floating extension of the glacier but
this shelf is cracking at an alarming
rate
like cracks on a windscreen um it's
fracturing at the surface so we're
finding that these cracks and these
crevasses and fractures are spreading
out across the eye surface essentially
weakening its fabric and allowing it to
eventually collapse um
so i think i think we're surprised
because the rate of change that these um
processes are occurring is is quicker
than we were expecting um the suggestion
is that it will collapse um within
possibly five years but certainly within
the next couple of decades
the ice melt draining from thwaites into
the amundsen sea already accounts for
four percent of rising sea levels
warm ocean water is getting underneath
the glacier weakening and melting the
ice shelf putting it at risk of collapse
scientists fear that if the thwaites
glacier were to melt entirely sea levels
could rise by as much as 65 centimeters
the impact of this would be felt
throughout the world including in the uk
we might see direct impacts such as
flooding or also indirect impacts such
as salinization of groundwater and we're
going to have to be prepared to respond
to that either building new barriers
such as the thames barrier in london
or being prepared to use our coastlines
in a different way for example accepting
that some areas may be lost and being
prepared to move towns and
infrastructure away from our current
coast
the ice earthquakes glacier is changing
dramatically it won't vanish overnight
instead this process will take decades
if not centuries but it is melting
rapidly and that will affect us all
charlotte lomas sky news